quelques jours je me posais une question
disons que ça caille et le smartphone le
plus cher au monde quels sont les
smartphones les plus chères au monde est
en fait en faisant des recherches je me
suis dit maintien est ce que ça pouvait
pas être un iphone de caviar vous savez
où nous iphone à plus de 10000 euros où
ils vont venir customiser les iphone je
me suis dit chef serait pas la caméra un
raid hydrogène y coûte déjà 1000
quelques balles ça me paraissait très
très cher et ce ne serait pas le sony
xperia pronostics bref parce que c'est
pas ces smartphones qui vont coûter
jusqu'à 10000 15000 euros ou alors 1000
2000 3000 euros et smartphones et plus
cher j'étais très loin de me douter que
le smartphone le plus cher au monde
coûte est allé à peu près 50 millions de
dollars 50 millions donc ce que je vais
faire ici je vous présentais les dix
téléphones des plus chers au monde en
commençant par le moins cher ce qui est
déjà énorme dans le top ten jusqu'aux
plus chers coûtent quasiment 50 millions
$ allez on y va c'est parti
le premier cette espèce de machin alors
cette espèce de machin si vous regardez
bien il est écrit ici boucheron il a été
fait en partenariat par boucheron enfin
bref c'est bouche ronde qui l'a habillé
de diam's alors le modèle il s'appelle
le virtues signé à cobra le virtuel
signature cobra et il coûte 310 mille
dollars ou est rien trois cent dix mille
dollars et en gros vous avez 388
éléments assemblés au uk ok vous avez
regardé ça peut paraître ridicule parce
qu'en fait on n'est pas se rassurer on
est vraiment sur un bon vieux téléphone
on a un écran de 5,2 pousse tout petits
qui est là c'est du full hd c'est un
smartphone qui a 4 gigas de ram et 64
giga de stockage on va pas être très
loin qu'une extension de mémoire en
carte micro sd si besoin est ok ok ça
c'est bien vous avez un appareil photo
qui est planqué ben je ne sais pas où
mais qui est planqué quelque part 21
mégapixels ok caméra de cette fille de
2,1 mégapixels un smartphone 14 ha et du
bluetooth gps et du nfc et il tourne sur
android 5.1 et ben ouais j'aime ça alors
là on monte un petit peu d'un prix on
passe à 488 1150 dollars c'est le goal
wisches révolution talent un ok on sent
très pixélisé ceux des photos que ce
soit un peu basse def et en fait j'ai vu
toutes ces infos on en a recherche sur
un site web d'ailleurs je le mets la
référence en bas dans la description des
restos qui voudraient s'y intéresse
alors c'est fait par une entreprise
suédoise qui s'appelle gold by gold by
gold by gold riche on va dire comme ça
on n'est pas sûr sinon c'est la
révolution alors ici vous avez un vieux
lille parce que je n'ai pas appris par
coeur voulait des diamants vous avez 29
carats de diamants à rien ça qu'ils sont
classés vs 1 je sais pas du tout ce que
c'est que la casse des vaisseaux je vous
cache pas que les diamants et moi
j'y connais pas grand chose on a de l'or
rose et blanc 18 carats en plan garder à
l'abri alors c'est pas hyper évident
comme ça mais vous avez tous des diam's
là sur le côté est du coup est
complètement sertie de diamants alors on
a eu aussi une batterie au lithium un
écran de 2,2 pouces et ben ouais
vachement bien alors aujourd'hui 2,2
pouces à frais marais tout le monde mais
à l'époque c'était bien vous pouvez
mettre jusqu'à 1000 contacts et si vous
souhaitez l'acheter si vous avez
quasiment 500 mille dollars et bien il
est disponible en langue française et ça
c'est la très très bonne nouvelle allez
on arrive dans le viiième smartphone le
plus cher on n'arrive carrément aux
millions de dollars rien que ça regardez
ça c'est le gresso louxor las vegas et
jackpot bing bang où ça fait 20 ans fait
rêver en tout cas comme ça alors ici
vous avez 180 grammes d'or vous avez des
diamants noirs de 45,5 car à chacun
alors je sais pas où ils sont les
diamants noirs est ce que c'est je
sépare sur le côté ce que vous avez là
je sais pas gérer vraiment alors que
vous avez un clavier à des le clavier la
justice il est composé de 17 sa fille
holly manuellement et gravé au laser
donc en fait lorsque vous appuyez sur
vous touche pour appeler votre mêlée et
bien vous appuyer sur des saphirs poli
manuellement gravé au laser va alors
s'il vous intéresse j'ai il faut
débourser 1 million de dollars rien que
ça et surtout là n'existe que trois dans
le monde donc dépêchez vous il va
peut-être falloir lâcher l'occasion et
avec un peu de chance vous aurez un
petit prix dessus quoique je suis pas
sûr que les saphirs sa décote énorme m
allez c'est est le smartphone le plus
cher au monde on arrive chez google vit
chez ses gaules vie selon goal vichy
avec un v s'appelle le million pour quoi
et bien parce qu'il coûte un million un
million de dollars rien que ça alors
c'est toujours une entreprise suédoise
qui vous l'a fait qu'il ait une forme
très bizarre on dirait un espèce de
poignard je sais pas un poignard ottoman
c'est très bizarre a été fabriquée en
2006 ce qui explique on est sur un
téléphone a pas sur un smartphone ici
vous égalez petite caméra de 2
mégapixels pour pouvoir prendre celle
fihri l'envoyer à votre tati sur une
belle résolution de 1600 par 1200 pixels
ben oui arrive ça vous a déjà deux gigas
de ram donc pour jouer au serpent ça
suffira largement lors je sais même pas
si on s'arrange suis pas sûr et vous
avez une batterie de 950 millions pérol
alors il existe en différentes couleurs
soyez tranquille en jaune en rose en
blanc et en or voilà comme ça vous serez
pas déçu cela est petite touche aux
retraites à finition or voyez là vous
avez des diam's de tous les côtés sur le
dessus partout sur les petites touches
au centre bref il ya de l'or il ya des
diamants ces bourses sont très kitsch
mais c'est beau mais ça coûte quand même
1 million $ allez on monte d'un cran on
arrive sur le smartphone un million
trois cent mille dollars us à un
téléphone un million trois cent mille
dollars et texas bangofa taper dessus
c'est un téléphone c'est le dimon crypto
smartphone christophe on voit pas ce
qu'il vient tout cryptée il vient vous
protéger celles des smartphones les plus
sûrs au monde va venir en crypté vos sms
vos conversations téléphoniques bref il
est totalement cryptées sécurisées alors
si vous voulez vraiment un truc en
crypté je pense qu'aujourd'hui
télégramme suffira largement on n'est
pas obligé de poser un million trois
cent mille mais si vous avez un million
trois cent mille qui dort sur un compte
et gruaux faire plaisir vous avez celui
là alors il est fait en or rose 18
carats avec 64 giga du stockage et une
batterie de 1350 mini-opéra ça marche
allez on va aller sur les smartphones
ils sont des choses qu'on connaît un
petit peu plus et si c'est un iphone et
ben ouais c'est un iphone 3gs et
l'iphone 3g kings button button pourquoi
parce que vous avez le bouton du roi au
centre ça vous aura pas échappé et
celui-là et coûte 2,5 millions de
dollars m ca 2,5 millions $ alors il est
fabriqué par un joaillier autrichien qui
s'appelle peter allison et notre bon
vieux peter nous l'a fabriqué en or
jaune massif 18 cas s'il vous plaît rien
que ça en or blanc et en en rose allez
la voyez là c'est dur hausse des ventes
est tout de l'or rose que vous avez ici
sur le contour et peut-être j'imagine
les touche là en or blanc j'en sais
fichtrement et là vous avez un contour
avec 138 diamant garder la 138 diamant
qui font tout le tour autant vous dire
que là on peut se la péter un peu et
vous avez un diamant gros boutons
diamant à 6,6 car là je vous le dis à
2,5 millions il est un peu rococo mais
vous pouvez vous la péter dans la rue
dans vos copains au lycée mais bon voilà
il faut encore leurs mines et au lycée
ne suis pas sûr et nous voilà arrivés
sur un autre iphone os montes de
génération c'est le goal stricker coach
michael est comme ça qu'il faut le
prononcent et iphone 3gs suprême à 3,2
millions de dollars regardez moi cette
oeuvre d'art même apple devrait pas
faire aussi bon ça fait bon ok alors lui
il a été fabriqué à liverpool un
businessman australien qui s'appelle
stuart yoox aux questions il est
similaire à l'iphone troisième je vous
montre tout à l'heure la loupe kingston
sauf que la différence c'est qu'il est
fait avec 136 diamants et 71 grammes
d'or 22 carats dont vous avez de leurs
22 carats qui va venir le recouvrir de
partouzes par son plus bel écrin et 136
diam's de partout et là des mois les
gros diam's là c'est magnifique ça vaut
de tous les côtés en fait il a mis dix
mois le concevoir être pour ça qu'ils
vont 3
dollars ou alors peut-être les diables
peut-être lors enfin bref c'est très
cher c mais bon j'ai pas d'ailleurs si
s'il vous plaît c'est téléphone si vous
voulez trouver beau au delà de la somme
au delà du montant astronomique on
pourra pas se payer est ce que c'est un
truc qui pourrait vous plaire d'avoir un
beau téléphone comme ça je sais pas elle
est au montant génération et en montant
prix on est ici sur l'iphone 4 dimon
rose èdition à hull millions de dollars
8 millions de dollars la bête alors
regardez les fabriquent également park
young qui a fabriqué le smartphone que
je vous ai présenté juste avant il a été
fabriqué à partie alors c'est écrit noir
sur blanc sans menottes attention pas se
planter à partir d'os rose avec plus de
500 diamants de plus de 100 carats
regardez ça voilà donc vous n'êtes plus
de 100 diam's qui font tout le tour
c'est la valeur de l'euro donc à
paillettes de l'ordre aux deux par tous
et voilà les boutons en allah et voilà
c'est juste magnifique vous avez
également 53 diamants qui constitue le
logo apple donc là gros vous avez vos
cinq sens diam's qui vont tout le tour
+53 ça vous fait quoi 553 diam's et ben
ouais pour faire des blagues vous avec
ça on a en tout 32 gigas de stockage et
puis alors si vous le voulez faut
vraiment s'il trouver la personne qui
l'a déjà parce qu'elle n'a que deux
exemplaires dans le monde faudra quand
même débourser ici vaut 8 millions de
dollars mais bon des fois on peut fonder
sa sur le pévèle donc allez ça va aller
on se rapproche on attaquait le deuxième
canal deuxième c'est celui-là c'est
l'iphone 4s un modèle encore plus
récents et leed gold et celui là ils
coûtent quasiment 2 millions il ya 9 4
millions de dollars alors il est
fabriqué également par stuart y sommes
il faut croire que notre ami stuart avec
ça fait plaisir on a fait un paquet
alors il est quand même plus atypiques
que les autres celui-là c'est le
smartphone le plus cher que stuart mais
jamais créé alors il est fabriqué à
partir d'or aux hommes avec plus de 500
diamants sans défaut sans aucun défaut
hockey totalisant jusqu'à 100 cas rare
donc à tous vos diam's là qui font le
tour eh bien ils n'ont absolument aucun
défaut sens car c'est voir dingue et
l'arrière est conçu avec de l'or 24
carats et le logo apple effet en or 24
carats avec 53 diamants alors je suis un
peu désolé j'ai pas la photo du dos mais
je vous laisse imaginer l'histoire alors
ici vous avez 64 tirs de stockage on
peut venir stocker un peu de musique
pour se faire plaisir il y en a deux
dans le monde voilà deux pour une petite
somme de 2 4 millions $ chacun ce qui
est quand même pas mal ce qui nous amène
sur le plus cher le plus cher c'est le
falcon supernova iphone si speed dimon
le nom est énorme et le prix également
48,5 millions de dollars 48,5 millions
de dollars alors qu'elle est fabriquée
par l'entreprise américaine falcone on
est un gros diamant rose à l'arrière a
engagé deux photos à vous montrer on
voit pas forcément gardés nous il ya un
diamant rose mais il yad'autres diamant
pour les gens qui ont un peu moins de
budget je vous l'expliqué ça vous allez
voir donc il est disponible en platine
ok on or 24 carats et en en rose et je
vous dis si vous n'avez pas le budget
alors vous avez une version en pin dimon
ok ça c'est la version qu'on accueille
la plus chère mais vous pouvez également
la voir en diamant orange ok coûtera à
42,5 millions de dollars donc oui c'est
déjà un peu plus raisonnable et puis
vous l'avez également en diamant bleu
qui est ici là à 32,5 millions de
dollars donc avoir un votre budget si
vous n'avez pas eu vraiment l'argent de
poche tout l'argent que vous espériez
avoir pour votre anniversaire ou pour
noël eh bien vous avez des versions un
peu moins cher c'est le falcon supernova
iphone 6 ping dimon et je vous dis 46
ans de suite via une 5 millions de
dollars c'est juste fou mais voilà je
vous ai montré les sma les téléphones
smartphones yade du smartphone ya du
téléphone en tout cas on va dire l'été
les smartphones je vous demande donc ici
il existe et les smartphones les plus
chers au monde ses voiles à des millions
de dollars il faut avoir beaucoup de
budget que ça doit être d'aider
milliardaire saoudien ou jeunes têtes
arrivent je sais pas qui se font plaisir
avec avec ces produits là tout cas ils
existent ils sont ils sont bien réels
ils sont peut-être un jour disponible
sur le marché de l'occasion donc
n'hésitez pas allez jeter un petit coup
d'oeil sur un bac market on sait jamais
sur dur conditionné ça peut vous la
péter un petit peu que ça voilà c'est
pas cette vidéo vous aurais intérêt si
ce nest très atypique 1,13 à pas mais
j'ai fait cette recherche et du coup ça
a piqué ma curiosité je voulais partager
avec vous je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous voulez que je vous
fasse d'autres vidéos comme ça pour
montrer des trucs un petit peu what the
fuck au niveau de la tête au niveau de
smartphones comme le marquer en bas en
commentaire alors rassurez vous on va
continuer à parler tech d'actualité on
va les tester des produits donc ça
arrive très bientôt de plein de
nouveautés donc ça c'est vachement cool
la vidéo comme dire vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà fait et puis je vous
embrasse un de gros bisous prenez soin
de vous beaucoup d'amour il a très vite
dans ma bulle
[Musique]